YouTube has a lot of kids content and a
lot of it is really messed up but even
though we're fathers ourselves we're not
qualified to make judgments on this
content so today we invited a child
psychologist Dr Tina Payne Bryson join
us I'm a pediatric and Adolescent
psychotherapist and I'm the founder and
executive director of a
multi-disciplinary clinical practice
called the center for connections she's
here to help us figure out if these
videos are dangerous for our children
[Music]
like Nastia is one of the biggest
channels on YouTube and she's basically
grown up from being a toddler on this
YouTube channel
[Music]
okay so I love that this is you know an
experience some kids would identify as
like they're hiding something about
themselves for peer approval but it's
not working for them it's all wrong you
get a f
oh I don't like that
oh she's got branding all over her
bedroom she sure does pictures of
herself
[Music]
so are we worried that kids are going to
worry that if they are out in the sun
something will happen that fast to their
face
I didn't I'm not even sure if kids are
really like that attuned to making fun
of kids with freckles no they're not no
we've just suggested a new way for the
kids to believe it
[Music]
here I imagine I can kind of tell where
it's going is that she feels bad they're
kind of mean to her she keeps hiding and
hiding and then something changes really
quickly and then she gives a message
that she hasn't been embodying she's
like always be yourself but what we've
just seen is five minutes of the
opposite of that message yeah and then
it keeps resetting exactly for getting
the message exactly so and kids are
gonna much more pick up on what they're
seeing her do as opposed to the verbal
sort of you know motivational point at
the end they're really probably taking
in more about the negative stuff
at school
wow hi Nicea
[Music]
I'm gonna sit here because your breath
stinks
looks pretty clean to me
my two toys are on the floor plus it's
kind of judgmental like her friends
invited her over she comes over and I
have a lint roller yeah she's kind of
micro picking on her friends as every
bit of imperfection it feels a little
Kardashian it's like oh you should have
a decorated room and you should have
nice clothes and you should be clean and
you should have toys and right yeah how
could you live like that right yeah like
you need a stylist at seven
it's also giving a lot of attention to
stuff we don't necessarily want to Value
see look now she's all like all of a
sudden she's grown up four years and
she's you know glammed out to be
accepted instead of actually just like I
accept you for who you are you're my
friend I like you because you're smart
and interesting or we have fun together
I mean it feels like the YouTube videos
I was just making fun of kids if they're
not clean and really here's the overall
message is you're not okay the way you
are like isn't this about diversity is
this still about diversity to me this is
like completely the opposite yeah trying
to turn her into another version of
herself yeah honestly that's
anti-diversity messaging here look oh
now they're even dressing the same yeah
getting weird I'm getting real word
Vibes yeah I don't like that it honestly
it's a little bit sexualizing of
everything and like I mean these little
girls look like they're seven or eight
um and that they should be making sure
that they look pretty and pulled
together I don't think so the world of
YouTube is one where the only thing
holding you back from getting more views
is usually your own Integrity
also we just go to the dark side I think
you're just gonna have to type
Spider-Man Elsa Okay so that sounds okay
you might skip around on this because
it's really hard to watch some of this
stuff
laughs
oh God yes and these are obviously
targeting kids yeah
[Music]
Spider-Man you take Elsa like two of the
most recognizable characters for kids
well and often boy and girl number ones
right exactly oh my God
[Music]
so strange it's hitting on bathroom
humor here right like having to go to
the bathroom and possibly vomit you know
barf and poop and
that's uh and then yeah pregnancy oh my
God it's tough to concentrate
it's assaulting your senses just a
little bit let's talk about thumbnails
you know in the world of YouTube you
want eyeballs and you are up against
everybody else that also wants your
eyeballs the kid pops onto YouTube and
this is what they see and everybody's
fighting for that child's attention what
is your reaction to looking at these
thumbnails here like when you guys look
at this as parents you can tell very
quickly product based candy based toy
based lots of stimulation right there
there's a girl going to the bathroom on
the beach we're not talking about a
potty training you know two-year-old
there she's prepubescent she's starting
puberty even it's disgusting YouTube can
do better I know they can do better what
is this another like poking a butt thing
ah yeah what are the things that kids
are curious about that don't really get
talked about you know needles pregnancy
toilets all that kind of stuff yep
supposedly YouTube started clamping down
on this stuff a little bit this only
came out two years ago
so I guess it's not that clamped down
whoa yeah look at Elsa's 9.4 hit it
let's go let's go dark side let's go
when something has this many views than
YouTube it's because kids are watching
it yeah
weird I mean Elsa's hot no one to
disagree with that
that's a one eye twitch pull up one of
the needle ones like let's just like
we're not gonna do it let's just let's
go over there getting sick after a fun
game
[Music]
oh god oh no
oh I touched a plant it's just a little
steroids
[Laughter]
her butt's big
oh what was that motion there that
looked really sexual I think they have
to stick something in her butt so they
definitely consulted with some child
psychologists before yeah you mean some
pornography producers
oh
yeah I would not want my kids watching
this yeah it'd be great if there were
some rules and regulations enforced
around what is kid content and what's
not kid content people are really
intentional about making it look like
kid content when actually it's harmful
to kids YouTube is putting it on their
servers it's part of their environment
and their ecosystem right they split
their ad YouTube takes 55 so yes Google
does bear responsibility 100 in this
situation sorry 55 so they benefit when
people put stuff out there that is
strange enough or dangerous enough that
it's more appealing if it's monetized
and granted like certain things can get
flagged when you're uploading videos
there's an internal review process where
you self-review you self-rate your video
there's a whole list there's also the
check box is this for kids you know yes
or no and don't forget that little blurb
that tells you to make sure you're
following all the laws and there's a
learn more link yeah it's performative
it's useless it's our responsibility to
make sure that we're curating safety in
terms of what they're seeing visually
and and if it's not a show that we know
will start and end and we feel good
about the content if it's something like
they could click on stuff or could take
them to something else adult eyes should
really be on it yeah I'm a big proponent
of obviously of like parents being
responsible for their children but I
also am a big proponent of companies
taking responsibility for what's on
their servers I would like to see any
videos with children younger than 13
just not eligible for monetization
personally it would it would eliminate
the entire exploitation industry around
filming your kids and forcing them to
work because once again there's zero
regulations protecting children like
when you were talking about the movie
industry you know there's not something
happening all over the place it's
happening you know in places where
there's money and there's Studios and
those kinds of things this could be
happening anywhere in the world and so
it's way more kids that have the
potential to be exploited than were
happening in studios and by the way one
of the things we want to say to our kids
is there might be some time you see
something that's confusing to you or
that makes you feel uncomfortable and
you should come and talk to me and we'll
make sense of it together just like the
conversation about sex or anything like
that isn't a one-time conversation it's
ongoing conversations we should be
having ongoing conversations with our
kids about what they're seeing how it
makes them feel what they learned about
them the biggest Behemoth in the world
of YouTube kids entertainment it's Coco
melon Coco melon is the largest kids
channel on YouTube and they kind of made
a name for themselves because they did a
lot of 3D animation they have a lot of
music-based stuff this portrays itself
as being educational is there any
education yeah
[Music]
foreign
yeah it's a song about a lesson or some
moral thing so you're getting that good
like rhythmic predictable Rhythm and the
Brain loves predictability which is why
you said it's a lot of them are they're
kind of the same predictability in our
nervous system is a cue of safety we
know what's coming my younger daughter
is like just phasing out of being
interested in this for her it's just the
music sticks with her you know just
tunes and Melodies and Rhymes
[Music]
so it's just kids reacting to hearing
the sound
[Laughter]
I think it is a great stare descent
it's really appealing isn't it I kind of
want to try this Rhythm like this also
is great for language acquisition any
kind of rhyming or rhythmic play with
words and letters I love that there's
diversity among the characters I also
love you're getting lots of reps around
school is fun and lovely and I love my
teacher look she helps me I heard I get
hurt at school she's gonna help me so
this is giving a message of you can
count on other grown-ups outside of your
parents to show up for you and take care
of you that's good to hear so one of the
coolest things about videos is that we
get a lot of awesome comments from
people they help us further our
knowledge of what's out there on YouTube
what is the channel That is popular
that's being watched by a lot of kids
that you think should not be on YouTube
and be being watched by kids also what
is the channel that you think has been
really positive and healthy for your
kids to watch what would you recommend
that people put in front of their
children hopefully can help us and
anyone else out there navigate all the
kids videos that are on YouTube is there
anything that you would hope people take
away from this video I think the idea
that just be thoughtful about what
they're being exposed to cumulatively it
really does make a difference it makes a
difference in terms of what they give
attention to what they give attention to
changes how their brain gets wired and
so we want to be really intentional
about what our child's giving attention
to in the world and the most important
thing is always relationships Dr Tina
Bryson thank you for taking the time to
join us is there anything that you'd
loved for our audience to perhaps look
at if they want to learn more about what
your kind of field of expertise is in
thank you yeah you can find me on social
media at Tina Payne Bryson and I've got
all kinds of books and all kinds of free
content available on my website thank
you so much for taking the time thanks
for having me appreciate it thank you